hello my name is Magnus it's 10 and I
work on the developers relation team
here at Google I'm going to talk about a
new exciting API that we are launching
called the Google Drive Android API
here's where I plan to cover today first
of all what is the Google Drive Android
API then I'm going to talk about the
features it has before I dig into two
very exciting ones namely the
transparent offline syncing and the user
interface component and finally I will
talk about how the Google Drive Android
API relates to the storage access
framework API released with KitKat so
first of all what is the Google Drive
API it's a native Android API written in
Java to access Google Drive content at
this time you might ask has this not
been done before and the answer is yes
but not as a native Android API and this
is very important because we have added
a lot of features that it enables you to
create shiny first-class Google Drive
apps on Android even without breaking a
sweat
one feature that makes this API very
useful is that it incorporated into
Google Play services a core part of the
Android device so to say and this has
several important benefits first of all
this greatly reduces the app size which
is perfect since it enables the app to
be downloaded faster it does not need to
be updated as often and it makes the app
have a smaller execution footprint for
example it will not take up as much
memory which is always a great thing of
course but perhaps an even more exciting
aspect of the Google Play services
integration is that the API will be
compatible running on all devices
starting with Gingerbread and this is no
little benefit as that will include 98%
of the Android devices out there that
means that you can rest assured that
this API can be used by everyone out
there just the time
little devices out there may not use it
but most of them will and that brings us
over to the features of the API so
pretty much everything you need to do to
create a great Google Drive app is
included in the API you can read write
update files and folders traverse folder
trees view and update metadata there is
a file picker user interface and you
have transparent offline syncing so
let's talk about there's a transparent
offline syncing to begin with as you are
aware an Android device is local storage
but Google Drive storage resides in the
cloud now one little peculiar thing
about mobile devices is that you can
never trust network connectivity
it changes Network all the time and it
is very often so that it has no network
access at all this makes storing things
in the cloud difficult but not with the
Google Drive API because the Google
Drive Android API will make sure that
your app will never fail when it writes
data and should communication with
Google Drive not be possible the API
will temporarily store data locally and
later sync that to Google Drive once
connectivity has been be established for
you as an Android developer this is of
course great because it takes all the
error management resulting from network
problems of your mind another great
feature of the Google Drive Android API
is the user interface component and in
the first release of the API there is a
folder and file navigation and selector
this makes it really easy to write an
application where the user needs to
select folders or files the only thing
you need to do is display this file
picker so how do you do that well first
of all you create an intent which opens
up the file activity builder then the
actual magic happens when the intent is
fired the user will be able to select
the files or folders that they want once
the user has selected their files the
result will be available in the on
activity result method as usual on
Android and finally you get the drive ID
for the content that you can work with
finally I would like to say some words
on the KitKat storage API and how it
relates to the Google Drive Android API
well although both can access and store
information on Google Drive there are
some fundamental design differences the
first one is that Google Drive Android
cool Android API only works with Google
Drive this allows Google to add things
to this API which are specific to Google
Drive on the other hand the storage API
free storage access framework is a
generic API and this enables it to work
with multiple different back-end storage
technologies not only Google Drive using
a single interface and here is a big
difference if you plan to do the very
tight and nice integration towards
Google Drive for your app then Google
Drive Android API is perfect another
feature of Google Drive is that the
developer can safely assume that the
user has already signed in to Google
Drive the storage access framework is
excellent if your app needs to access
multiple storage technologies and not
just drive and of course having said all
of this there is nothing stopping you
from using both at the same time of
course all Google Drive specific
features as well as a generic
integration with other storage
technologies you should also be aware
that the storage access framework will
only work on devices that are running
KitKat and that's what I wanted to
present to you today we are very excited
to launch the Google Drive Android API
and the feature it contains now go out
there and create great apps using this
android and drive api and don't forget
to tell us all about it